[Música]
tengo 32 años soy patrón de profesión y
desde hace un tiempo me empecé a dedicar
a la educación superior específicamente
para trabajar con estudiantes de mi
carrera hoy les quiero contar una bonita
historia que tiene que ver con el cómo
he desarrollado el área de la educación
desde mi desempeño hace 28 años que
estoy inmerso en el sistema de educación
de nuestro país y siempre ha ocurrido lo
que lo más probable que a ustedes
también les haya pasado existe una
persona un hombre una mujer que se para
frente a nosotros y nos empieza a decir
cuáles son aquellos tópicos aquellos
contenidos o temáticas que son
importantes que nosotros tengamos en
mente porque a futuro nos van a servir
siempre me cuestione en muchas
oportunidades porque estaba aprendiendo
lo que estaba aprendiendo y eso ocurrió
en muchas seguidillas de oportunidades
que tuve en la educación primaria y en
la educación secundaria es así que como
yo les empiezo a contar esta historia y
yo pienso que ustedes se están
imaginando esta imagen para que ustedes
sepan yo soy la tercera persona que está
sentado a la izquierda
bueno no en el viaje estudio la broma
porque en mis tiempos si existían las
fotografías a color lo importante que
quede en mente en este caso es el
clásico imagen que existe de la
educación tradicional donde está esta
persona el docente que se para frente a
los estudiantes a través de un
aprendizaje que es denominado pasivo
donde todo está centrado en el docente
quince años antes yo ingresé al sistema
de educación superior e ingresé a
estudiar una carrera tradicional de
nuestro país ingresé a estudiar en una
universidad tradicional y en un momento
pensé y dije aquí van a ver cambios todo
el mundo en la educación secundaria me
decía prepárate para la universidad
porque es algo sumamente difícil y
distinto y he aquí voy a encontrar
quizás desafíos o experiencias que van a
ser muy diferentes a lo que yo he vivido
al llegar a la universidad me encontré
con la sorpresa de que era prácticamente
lo mismo los docentes o las docentes
estaban frente a uno a un montón de
personas en un auditorio y empezaban
nuevamente a dar contenidos y temáticas
que era importante que aprendiera cosas
que en un principio a veces ni siquiera
entendía de lo que estaban hablando pero
habían tres grandes diferencias uno los
auditorios eran muchísimo más grandes
ahora ya no tenía treinta compañeros
sino que tenía 90 y aparte la
iluminación era mejor el otro punto que
me llamó la atención es que cuando no
estudié una carrera en salud a medida
que van avanzando los años empezamos a
hacer prácticas de los hospitales en los
centros de atención en salud y lo que
ocurrió en ese momento
es que empezó a ver una dinámica en la
cual existía un profesor una profesora
que era el mentor o la mentora y que me
enseñaba estos aspectos importantes que
yo tenía que manejar al tener relación
con los pacientes o con las personas
esta relación mentor estudiante persona
o paciente es algo que en mí desde mi
punto de vista generó un aprendizaje
significativo y efectivamente al
reflexionar dije hay cambios la
universidad efectivamente entrega
herramientas que son distintas el trato
con los contenidos se ve de una manera
distinta y es así como empecé a
reflexionar en el momento y dije ya
quizás si podemos hacer cambios quizás
pueden existir diferencias en el como
como académicos podemos saber abordar
diferentes temáticas pero al igual que
ustedes me imagino que pensarán en algún
momento también uno tiene un momento en
que dice es difícil hacer cambios porque
no mejor dejamos las cosas tal como
están que muchísimo más fácil
no si me di cuenta más adelante que si
se podrían hacer cambios ahora les
cuento una experiencia cuando yo regrese
como matrona una de las primeras
actividades que tuve que realizar fue
una educación en un colegio fui a hacer
una charla de educación sexual con
estudiantes de octavo nivel estoy
hablando de adolescentes de 13 o 14 años
a los cuales yo tenía que mostrar cómo
se utilizaba en una serie de métodos
anticonceptivos entre salí y al salir
tenía unos inmensos ojos de sorpresa
porque aquellos estudiantes me dijieron
y me enseñaron más cosas de las que yo
sabía que había aprendido en la
universidad se imaginen ustedes todas
las cosas que me pudieron haber enseñado
esos adolescentes de 13 14 años ahora de
que me di cuenta y que reflexione al
respecto que efectivamente estas
personas son desafiantes del siglo 21
son innovadores naturales son nativos
tecnológicos son personas que desde que
nacen tienen computadores tienen
celulares dispositivos electrónicos en
sus manos por lo tanto en la enseñanza
que ellos han tenido desde un comienzo
ha sido sumamente distinta a la que
youtube
cuando empecé a trabajar en la
universidad tras el regreso y esta gran
experiencia que tuve empecé a pensar en
cómo podíamos generar ciertos cambios
respecto a las metodologías de
innovación y es así como yo y un
conjunto de colegas que trabajamos en
conjunto algunas autoridades también de
la facultad me dijeron hay un proceso de
innovación curricular efectivamente va a
ver un cambio de paradigma en la
educación que estamos entregando a los
estudiantes ojos entregando a los
estudiantes y esto es algo que en un
momento dije efectivamente vamos a poder
llegar a lo que yo había visto en vídeos
en fotografías que era una educación
centrada en el estudiante una educación
que utilizaba diferentes recursos para
favorecer el aprendizaje y no donde ya
el docente seguía siendo el centro del
este
aspecto ahora un estudiante en un
momento me dijo profe porque no va usted
a conocer el programa yo antes que tiene
la facultad de medicina de la
universidad de chile que está frente a
la cafetería yo obviamente de manera muy
obediente me dirigí frente a la caseta
golpea la puerta me abrieron un montón
de jóvenes le digo yo ya tenía 25 años
eran más jóvenes que yo y los
estudiantes me empiezan a contar de qué
se trata este programa de ayudantes y
obviamente venía con un pensamiento que
decía un programa ayudante me imagino
que son estudiantes que solamente van a
apoyar al docente en las crías que
tenían y me di cuenta radicalmente que
no era así es así como que me contaron
la historia de cómo comienza el programa
ayudantes que fue llamado programa
ayudantes docentes habían 16 estudiantes
de la universidad de chile que se reúnen
en un cubículo un espacio muy pequeño de
la biblioteca de nuestra facultad que
empiezan a generar un montón de ideas
locas las cuales plasman en un facebook
y ese facebook lo titulan como programa
ayudante docente cuando ellos me dicen
programa ayudante docente yo lo primero
que pienso guau es un programa de
ayudantes que debe tener una innumerable
cantidad de recursos disponibles tiene
que tener un gran presupuesto académicos
expertos trabajando con estos ayudantes
y efectivamente los estudiantes cuando
yo comencé esta charla me dicen profe en
realidad no tenemos docentes que estén
aquí
somos los ayudantes que son los mismos
16 que se incrementarán en el tiempo y
obviamente tenemos 0 pesos para poder
hacer todas estas innovaciones con este
escenario y dije ok empecemos a trabajar
y empecé a conocer y me empezaron a
mostrar todas las actividades de
innovación que empezaron a generar estos
estudiantes ahora me mostraron por qué
era tan importante el programa ayudantes
docentes o pat para la facultad y tenía
grandes tres pilares fundamentales el
primero los ayudantes efectivamente
estaban enfocados en la docencia la
enseñanza era el foco que tenían estos
ayudantes no otras áreas que podrían
haber asumido y además tenían la
obligatoriedad de tener que innovar para
favorecer el aprendizaje activo y además
todos los resultados que ellos obtengan
y el impacto que tienen tiene que ser
publicado tiene que ser mostrado a la
comunidad científica y también entre
ellos por eso tenían que investigar a su
vez uno del aspecto más importante es la
motivación los ayudantes eran
seleccionados porque tenían ganas de
hacer actividades educativas y de
innovar no va bien al principio otros
incentivos y eso es algo que ha
funcionado muy
en este programa por último es un
programa que desde desde un comienzo fue
creado y gestionado y administrado 100%
por estudiantes no había ningún
académico que estuviera participando
directamente en un inicio con estos
estudiantes y el programa funcionaba
impecablemente ahora cuáles eran los
propósitos que tenía este programa y que
sigue teniendo al día de hoy en primer
lugar generar lo que se llama un impacto
pero positivo para favorecer o ayudar en
el proceso de innovación curricular de
la facultad en este caso también
difundir lo que se llama la motivación
educativa esta gran motivación que los
estudiantes y las estudiantes tienen
tiene que ser esparcido y tiene que ser
esparcido a todos los actores incluyendo
sus compañeros otros ayudantes y el
cuerpo docente favorecer la formación
académica es sumamente fundamental para
poder implementar metodologías activas y
metodologías innovadoras y es por eso
que el par por programa ayudante docente
se ha dedicado a apoyar también a los
académicos desde este punto de vista
ahora 16 estudiantes comenzaron pero
como ustedes observan en este gráfico
había un incremento exponencial hasta el
año 2019 de llegar a tener más de 700
estudiantes que están participando en
diferentes ayudantías en este programa
al principio comenzaron sólo con una
ayudantía sin embargo hoy en día hay más
de 995 cursos que incluyen el programa
ayudante docente dentro de las
estrategias que tienen para mejorar la
docencia que imparte y a su vez 8 las 8
carreras de la facultad de medicina de
la universidad de chile tienen en
algunos de sus cursos este programa
implementado ahora como hicieron los
estudiantes para poder difundir esta
gran gama de información que tenían uno
de los pilares fundamentales del pub es
la solidaridad y el trabajo serio por lo
tanto es importante mostrar todo lo que
el padre hace y así se crea la página de
ayudantes docentes la cual incluye
aspectos como por ejemplo la
transparencia todos los documentos que
son generados en el parque están
publicados en esta plataforma está
difundida quiénes son los ayudantes
cuáles son las ayudantías quién es la
directiva entre otros e incluso todos
los materiales de innovación
disponibles también en la plataforma
esta plataforma que es gratuita de libre
acceso recibe más de 250 personas al día
de más de 77 países incluyendo dentro de
ellos archivo ahora cuáles son las
grandes metodologías innovadores que el
programa ayudante docente ha podido
generar en el último tiempo una de ellas
la generación de vídeos hay un canal en
youtube que está el nombre del programa
ayudante docente que tiene más de 280
vídeos disponibles de acceso liberado
para cualquier persona que simplemente
haga el clic en la plataforma con más de
9 mil 500 suscritos que solamente al
subir un vídeo reciben una notificación
inmediata que les dice que está
disponible algún otro vídeo
también otras iniciativas de innovación
que el programa ayudante docente ha
podido implementar es por ejemplo el uso
de streaming la grabación de un docente
o de un ayudante que genera una
actividad interactiva con los
estudiantes a distancia a los
estudiantes no necesitan estar presentes
en el aula necesitan tener esta
interacción con el docente se pueden
hacer preguntas e incluso entregar
feedback inmediatos también habían
habido por ejemplo publicaciones de
libros digitales de diferentes
disciplinas los cuales están disponibles
solamente con un link o un código qr a
su vez se han confeccionado por ejemplo
aplicaciones digitales las cuales han
servido para que los mismos ayudantes
sus compañeros e incluso profesionales
ya egresados de la carrera puedan
mejorar la eficacia en la atención
clínica
también hay cursos que han sido
implementados a través de plataformas
digitales como la que aparece en la
imagen que permiten que el estudiante no
necesariamente esté en una relación
presencial con el docente o los docentes
sino que puede trabajar a distancia con
él o con ella finalmente una de las
últimas innovaciones lo que ustedes
observan en este vídeo la confección de
imágenes o de vídeos en tercera
dimensión en este caso para un programa
o una asignatura de anatomía en la cual
los estudiantes tienen la posibilidad de
ver los gestos anatómicos del oído medio
simplemente teniendo un celular que
ponen delante de sus ojos y siguen el
recorrido de aquellos hitos que son más
importante incluso interactuando con la
imagen haciendo clic en las zonas que
necesiten más información para dar
entender lo que necesitan entender
todo esto obviamente ha sido mostrado en
diferentes partes otro de los puntos
importantes del pater a publicar era
investigar y en ese sentido el programa
ayudante docente ha hecho publicaciones
tanto a nivel nacional en congresos en
seminarios como a nivel internacional e
incluso ha sido premiado en congresos
internacionales como una de las mejores
metodologías de innovación que debería
ser replicada en instancias de educación
superior también existen una serie de
publicaciones en revistas científicas
indexadas respecto a los resultados e
impacto que ha tenido este programa
por último el programa tiene la
capacidad de poder generar una de las
grandes funciones académicas que es la
vinculación y la extensión con el medio
desde este punto de vista el programa yo
ante docentes confeccionó un facebook un
fanpage llamado zona salud que tiene más
de 9 mil 500 inscritos los cuales pueden
obtener información didáctica y
divertida respecto a aspectos que tienen
que ver con la salud de las personas e
incluso esta información ha sido
utilizada por los centros de salud
familiar para poder proyectarlas en las
televisiones que se encuentran en las
salas de espera y así evitan el hecho de
que estén publicados o estén presentando
programas de la televisión abierta
también el pad en conjunto con otras
unidades ha podido implementar el primer
curso en salud en español en la
plataforma global
urcera respecto a los cuidados de la
atención del recién nacido
las autoridades de la facultad han
reconocido la importancia de tener un
programa de ayudantes docentes que
genera este tipo de impacto por eso en
sus redes sociales también ha informado
respecto a los grandes resultados que se
han obtenido y la importancia de tener
un programa funcionando continuamente
esto también ha ocurrido a nivel local
en la universidad donde el pac ha podido
trabajar en conjunto con otros centros
de enseñanza y aprendizaje para generar
por ejemplo investigaciones respecto al
impacto que podría generar también había
un impacto positivo a nivel país en
donde han habido otras universidades que
han tomado contacto con la directiva del
pac para poder implementar esos mismos
centros un programa ayudantes docentes y
poder replicarlo obviamente en bajo bajo
sus necesidades y esto también ha
ocurrido a nivel internacional algunas
universidades han tenido contacto con el
programa ayudante docente y han pedido
el apoyo para poder implementarlo en
estos centros
yo me pregunto y me imagino que ustedes
en algún momento se preguntan si toda
esta maravilla efectivamente ha podido
llegar a los académicos que era un punto
que en un principio era bastante difícil
quizás para poder llegar y como ustedes
observan en esta imagen existe un
estudiante un ayudante de docente que
está realizando una presentación en lo
que se llama croma el fondo verde
también hay otro tipo de vídeos que
realizan como por ejemplo escritos o
actuados y estos vídeos o otras
metodologías de innovación han podido
llegar entonces para ser motivadas a los
docentes efectivamente esto ha ocurrido
los docentes y las docentes de la
facultad ha logrado empaparse en lo que
es el padre en el proceso de innovación
del aprendizaje activo de los y las
estudiantes por eso como ustedes
observan los docentes empezaron a
trabajar con esta misma metodología y el
pad ha logrado acompañarlos en un
proceso continuo para poder enseñarles y
explicarles el cómo funciona estas
distintas metodologías finalmente y un
mensaje que me gustaría que ustedes se
llevaran a sus casas el día de hoy es el
hecho de que consideren que los
ayudantes docentes deberían ser partes
del proceso de innovación curricular son
parte fundamental de los la tríada de
actores que tiene que estar en el
proceso de innovación curricular estos
ayudantes docentes son facilitadores que
permiten que el aprendizaje activo se
esparza y se difunda entre todos
nosotros incluyendo a estudiantes
ayudantes académicos e incluso
funcionarios a su vez el programa
permite o se transforma en un formador
de formadores estos ayudantes docentes
que se están formando en el programa
ayudante van a ser los futuros docentes
son los docentes del mañana del futuro
aquellas personas que van a trabajar
junto con nosotros ojalá en la
universidad y para finalizar si ustedes
me preguntan si este programa realmente
generó la motivación o el impacto en el
equipo docente aparte de hacer
grabaciones yo les puedo decir
efectivamente que sí y un ejemplo de
esto soy yo que desde mi experiencia les
vengo a contar que como académico
pudimos publicar en conjunto con el pac
el primer curso en curso era en español
y es gratuito de libre acceso que a la
fecha tiene más de 8.600 personas que se
han inscrito
obteniendo su certificado como tal y
además agradezco enormemente la
consideración que el programa your ente
docente ha tenido en este caso de
incorporar en el proceso a los
académicos incluso llegando a el
beneficio de que hoy en día yo fui
nombrado hace poco tiempo como el primer
académico que participa en el programa y
el primer director general que está
trabajando junto a los ayudantes
docentes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]